how does it feel being back just for
laughs montreal i can't wait
i'm so excited it's uh it feels great it
feels great to be anywhere after the
last two or three years but just for
laughs is very special to me it was uh
probably it was well over 20 years ago
that i played just for laughs for the
first time and it was such a huge thrill
this hour is 22 minutes i was a member
of the cast we hosted a gala and then i
came back many times since and hosted
gallus
but uh
this show i mean this this festival i'm
not only um appearing on a gala but i
hosted the comedy night in canada show
last night
and uh it was an incredible lineup of
all canadian comedians it was just it
was so it was great yeah how would you
describe the comedy scene in canada
right now
well i i there's many there are more
comedians now than ever before that's
awesome oh by by probably a factor of a
thousand than when the comedians that i
have worked with for many many years as
writers mainly when they were part of
the comedy scene that
involved people like norm mcdonald
people like that there actually weren't
a lot of comedians now you go to any
city and there's a stand-up comedy scene
when i grew up in saint john's
newfoundland there was no stand-up
comedy scene at all i was an adult
before i saw a stand-up comedy now
there's a thriving stand-up comedy scene
there yeah oh no they're everywhere
yeah good especially in canada no i want
to hear that um okay so then what is
going to be turned into your comedy
night with rick mercer special coming up
this fall well that is i've been doing a
lot of stand-up when i left
uh the mercer report that's what i
wanted to do i wanted to go across the
country with just for laughs and bring
canadian comedians across the country
and i had done that before like 17 years
ago but i was a host and i've always
been a host of things but i wanted to go
out as a true stand-up so i went out and
i would do 20 minutes off the top and 10
minutes in the second act and
we've done the tour twice now uh they're
two of the most successful just for last
tours which is phenomenal because it's
all canadian and um so what
the last tour we went from st john's to
victoria but we didn't come to montreal
because we knew we were going to do last
night's show so it was a combination of
everyone that was on the road this year
plus sophie buttle who was on the
previous tour right who's tearing it up
yeah he's just destroying all over north
america now is it okay what's the
different energy it requires for you to
host something and then actually be on
stage as a stand-up comic well stand-up
comics will talk a lot about that
there's a lot of stand-ups the only time
they feel normal i've heard this a lot
actually this is when they're on stage
this is what i've heard yeah um
thankfully knock wood i'm not that
person
i know a lot of them and i don't want to
walk in their shoes but it is a
phenomenal feeling and there's nothing
like it and it's and it's
it takes a lot of work to get to the
point where you can go out in front of
1500 people i don't know how you all do
it but
when when you pull it off the work is
worth it because it's just a feeling
like no other and i like to keep it
topical so it's a constant process and
uh yeah i like it i like it very very
much and it's completely it's the
opposite of television which i did for
so long and like you do you know you
need so much to do television you need
the lights and the producer and the
camera operator and all these things the
building everything and that this is
this is a small operation
but with stand-up
it's just it's
me and the suit back
i'm ready to go
that's exciting that must be really fun
you know for the years that you've been
doing this it must you know you seem
like you're still having a great time
yeah i i wouldn't be doing it if i
wasn't really enjoying it quite frankly
i'd figure out something else to do
i love that um i'm gonna admit i've been
stalking your instagram just a little
bit i want to live in your home in
newfoundland it's beautiful your views
are incredible it is uh it is right on
the ocean in newfoundland and it was my
pre-pandemic project really and everyone
thought i was kind of bonkers but then
the pandemic happened and suddenly i had
this place on the ocean so they thought
it was you're ahead of the curve i was
ahead of the curve a little bit yeah but
is that like your most you know you go
there and that's your peaceful place
yeah well during the pandemic thankfully
i had a job to do and that was to write
a book so i had a shed
i was sad yeah i was
i was more interested in building the
shed than the actual house
so the shed is wired it's got tv lights
it's got it
oh yeah and that's where i wrote the
book and you know it's got doors that
open i can look at the ocean see the
whales i'll be looking at the whales
from there
this time tomorrow oh my goodness well
that is such a lovely life you've earned
it and it's so nice getting to talk to
you i mean we were just talking about
how excited we were to see you coming in
we've watched your show so yeah thanks
for being here thank you
cheers